el reino de la magia está recortando
gastos en todo el mundo la compañía Walt
Disney emplea unas 220.000 personas pero
recientemente anunció que despedirá a
7000 de ellas o el 3.6% de su fuerza
laboral como parte de un plan para
ahorrar 5.500 millones de dólares la
empresa dijo que también está haciendo
otros recortes de costos operativos la
reestructuración se produce luego de que
Disney publicara sus ganancias del
primer trimestre del año el ingreso neto
de 1280 millones de dólares estuvo por
debajo de las expectativas de vuelta
como sí O u desde noviembre Bob aiger
les dijo a los analistas de Wall Street
que el enfoque de Disney es volverse más
rentable y eventualmente obtener
ganancias para su servicio de
transmisión de Disney Plus estamos
comprometidos a funcionar de manera
eficiente especialmente en un entorno
desafiante estábamos como empresa en una
carrera armamentista mundial para los
suscriptores
Disney Plus informó su primera
disminución en las suscripciones y
pérdidas de más de mil millones de
dólares un inversionista activista
también había estado presionando por
cambios y un asiento en la junta algo
que Disney está en contra en última
instancia el activismo gira alrededor de
Disney y creo que Iker y la junta son
muy conscientes de eso y es por eso que
necesitas hacer cosas como esta para ser
felices a todos porque las paredes
podrían comenzar a derrumbarse bastante
pronto
I girl dijo que planea pedir que se
restablezca en los dividendos Este es el
tercer plan de reestructuración de
Disney en cinco años los recortes son la
forma en que aiger les dice a los
accionistas que está volviendo a
encarrilar al gigante de los medios